françois durpaire merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors pour
commencer peut-être se rappelle pourquoi
washington est particulièrement attentif
à ce qui se passe en mer de chine
méridionale
la syndication de évidemment de
puissance et de d'opposition entre les
deux simplement ce qu'il faut souligner
c'est que ça fait penser un peu
historiquement vous savez la fin du 19e
siècle
on parlait de la volonté des états unis
de d'écarter toutes les puissances du du
sfr américaine vous rappelez peut-être
de la doctrine monroe du corollaire
roosevelt à la doctrine monroe et c'est
ce qu'ils essayent de faire la chine en
dix ans ne touchez pas à l'asile à
l'asie c'est la sphère d'influencé de la
chine mais a quand même grande
différence c'est que les états unis ont
des alliés dans la région
brunei la malaisie les philippines
taïwan et le vietnam ont aussi des
revendications dans la mer de chine
méridionale et tous ces états sont des
alliés des etats unis
donc évidemment la chine est quand même
géographiquement plus embêté et sur le
plan géostratégique plus embêté que ne
l'était les états unis à la fin du 19e
siècle alors en tout cas sur ce dossier
la position des états unis a toujours
été la même néanmoins comment comprendre
ce changement de ton qui semble plus
ferme finalement qu'auparavant c'est
sans doute à comprendre aussi dans le
dans le cadre de l'élection américaine
donald trump aujourd'hui veut donner des
gages à son électorat il a fait sa
campagne vous vous rappelez sur son
opposition avec la chaise il a même dit
que son adversaire
joe biden était l'ami des chinois ça
n'aurait pas de sens de faire cette
campagne si lui et était aussi la vie
des chinois dont il a besoin
quand même quatre mois avant l'élection
et vous verrez que la situation ne
s'améliorera pas d'ici le 3 novembre
prochain
et bien sûr un certain nombre de
dossiers vous savez la mairie de nice
est un des dossiers mais il y en a bien
d'autres d'opposition
avec la chine peut évidemment citer la
5g
on peut citer hong kong on peut citer la
guerre commerciale qui continue et donc
il ya un certain temps une certain
nombre d'oppositions un certain nombre
de dossiers qui évidemment sont très
tendues aujourd'hui entre les deux
premières puissances mondiales
mais finalement on quoi être anti
chinois finalement ça rapporte des voix
de l trump si vous voulez d'un train il
a construit sa campagne électorale sur
le nationaliste sur un nouveau
nationaliste faire d'eux des états unis
un pays à nouveau puissance evans son
slogan électoral alors cela dit vous
savez c'est dans la tête de donald trump
c'est peut-être comme s'il avait
peut-être pris pour acquis le fait que
la chine était une puissance qui allait
continuer à progresser et à prendre la
place des états physiques c'est pas sûr
du tout et au moins il ya 3 il ya trois
donné qu'on ne parle presque jamais la
première c'est désormais la fragilité
démographique le vieillissement de
lâcher de lâcher le batteur 400 millions
de travailleurs au cours du prochain
siècle
la deuxième chose c'est bien les marchés
d'exportation la chine dépend des
marchés d'exportation dépend à 15% de
l'europe
or l'europe et est aujourd'hui est bien
un marché moribond un espace moribond
sur le plan économique les états unis 19
% pour les exportations chinoises et
baisse de 17% depuis l'été 2010 8
jusqu'à janvier 2020 et surtout la
faiblesse de la chine sur le plan
géographique et géostratégique dont je
parle et vous savez la chine dépend de
dieu du golfe pour son pétrole de
l'afrique pour ses ressources et pour
ses exportations grande partie aussi de
l'europe
et bien c'est trois zones sont contrôlés
par la marine américaine le contrôle des
mers c'est toujours le contrôle du monde
et vous voyez il ya peut-être encore un
temps on parle souvent de des états unis
ils vont devenir la deuxième puissance
du monde derrière la chine vient
peut-être que tous
tous ces développements actuels montrent
que les états unis ont peut être encore
de longues années devant elle c'est
toujours la première puissance du monde
grâce à sa marine alors en tout cas la
tension monte de plus en plus avec
l'envoi de deux porte-avions américain
est ce qu'on peut craindre une escalade
aujourd'hui alors oui vous savez ce que
développe ce qui se développe beaucoup
aux états unis s'est vidée d'une guerre
possible tout simplement entre la chine
les etats unis et ont sévèrement souvent
le spécialiste de la diplomatie au piège
de thucydide qu'est ce que ça veut dire
la guerre du péloponnèse vous vous en
souvenez peut-être du côté de la
puissance émergente c'est-à-dire
d'athènes vous avez la chine et du côté
de sparte vous avez des états unis la
thèse de 7,2 cette idée de thucydide
c'est qu'il ya forcément un conflit
entre les deux puissances ne s'est pas
sûr du tout et pour trois raisons très
rapidement la première c'est que la
chine n'a pas nécessairement de
velléités militaire à l'extérieur de la
mer de chine méridionale
c'est pas du tout la volonté de la chine
de dominer le monde militairement
la deuxième raison c'est évidemment
l'interdépendance économique entre les
deux états qui ont tellement tellement
d'intérêts en commun on voit pas
pourquoi il se ferait la guerre et puis
la troisième raison c'est que notamment
par vous savez le projet des routes de
la soie
la chine va rogner sur des territoires
et des intérêts que les états unis ont
déjà mis de côté on prenez l'exemple de
la spec évidemment la chine aujourd'hui
est omniprésente en afrique mais les
états unis sont déjà enfin on n'en a pas
besoin de la chine pour être absent de
ces territoires là donc pour ces trois
raisons au moins
probablement c'est une analyse et cd que
la mienne
la guerre entre la chine et les états
unis n'aura probablement jamais lieu
merci beaucoup ont donc à françois
durpaire pour votre analyse je rappelle
que vous êtes historien spécialiste des
états unis